I am here how big Hey
all right let's begin okay my hair
getting cropped out because my hair
needs being the framin alright this game
was made by the same guy I think you can
tell right away just by looking at the
style of it grow your head you remember
that game I made a video that it was
really cool cool game so I'm excited to
check this one out as well are you ready
to get weirded out my intro was not
enough for you well then let's keep
going
a is for antlers of course and arch and
lineman amble amble yes I don't know
what I'm doing in case you're wondering
animals I have ever every genes I got a
star B B is for bungo beard beard house
I can't grow a beard either and it's not
fair what a nice luscious little now God
because this is actually a really nice
game for kids yeah like I wish I learned
at the alphabet like this hi little
butterfly butterfly oh man I got hey
whoa
my say is terrified of butterflies I can
kind of understand like I mean look at
it
go away there you go more great next one
C for circus or Kelsey or Kent no wait
no cone cone that's what I said
Spiner ooh are we gonna go through the
entire [ __ ] alphabet let's get take a
[ __ ] bus Oh
oh my god such amazing animations it is
oh my god it's caterpillar oh it went to
space now it's back alright next letter
will you guess with me come on guess
with me
D is for D dinosaur door god damn it
dawn ah I'm so bad
I shouldn't be that hard to guess these
dust desk daydream get away enough time
for you daydreams
are y'all daydreams [ __ ] II
embryo egg [ __ ] go away
Oh God I don't think it's supposed to
have teeth that's kind of scary you want
the egg I think it was yang come back
here egg I'm sorry I got changed my mind
go in eat elephant
there it is awesome goodbye elephant it
was nice knowing out [ __ ] [ __ ] next
letter F Felix
fantastic fabulous foot [ __ ] what yeah
feathers yeah didn't get her
oh look at you Bruce
get it get it flexible I would say to
unintentionally they had that one in
there fine
g-great
goggles jee-ah
guitar [ __ ] I'm pro at playing
this [ __ ] garden ha this is such a weird
game to play
I have no idea what's going down ghosts
oh there's ghosts in the garden with the
guitar yeah I heard you the first time
lady it's no no point in repeating
yourself have each hand pound horse
horse and [ __ ] honey
hair was so close it's a party girl it's
a party that's disgusting
alright this game is like subtly
disturbing yes why I like it anyway I
highbury I iceberg ice Wow
give it away give it away ice uh a glove
a blow right yeah inside what are they
doing inside Eagle what a build an eagle
in one day you know what one inflatable
inflate yeah that's right
alright alright alright alright next
letter J what should it be
that was Jo Kang Jae come on what do we
got Bryce jiggle
yeah yeah that's what I'm talking about
girl all right all right all right
hmm juggle yes no no no not for you
all right fine hmm jellyfish
it's so cool so creating this game so
cool
whoever is it whoever just doing these
is obviously super talented you can
really tell all right let's move on
kay-kay
Kellogg's [ __ ] kettle whoo that's
what I'm talking about girl hey if I
have to go em again good night yeah what
Alice on K Oh kill you a scope is that
what they're called
how ladies so okay I should have kept
one and I see a lady and I love these
it's Mike Mike childhood right here
large log like how proud I feel free for
figuring them out before I'm like yeah I
got a log [ __ ]
that's rack what you go you didn't get
it before me though so don't worry about
it
lame lazy all right
lizard I'm sir such amazing innovation
oh my god what is happening
Lu oh my that's awesome
all right next letter M mmm old March
yeah I knew it
March whoa you got a to bet you didn't
bet you did
you're probably smart monster look how
high they say my search I know yeah you
know the time - oh actually kind of want
to make out with us
is that weird you wanted to shut up uh
n is for Nigerian what is that what is
this neighborhood neighborhood you
neighbors so weird
oh god yeah yeah NIC nod that's
brilliant that's really brilliant oh oh
orchestra oval orange orange again this
is really look like an orange orbit wow
that's cool man I love these games it
would fit really well an iPad I bet
they're gonna come out oh sorry
okay what is the next one gonna be hmm
back to the orange or ostrich is
everything call ostrich nice
come here little ostrich what is orange
inside you shake that ass for me shake
that ass for me come on girl shake that
ass alright well I don't want to say it
I have paper nice ponder plan in my foot
platypus
there must be platypus what am I missing
here
what pinwheel pinwheel oh man I can't
either man I don't know I don't know I
don't know why I thought that would work
up you just gotta let nature pin
here's the orchestra
what is it called hurry up come on kids
I like the duck yeah yeah
all right you cute hmm that's not many
words I'm curious it quash ha ha ha I
should've guessed
come on I'm a duck [ __ ]
Oh No
now the mothers quick oh I don't know
what happened it's a sealed recording uh
I don't think I'm solving this right you
have to solve the whole thing oh my god
okay I can do it what is it going to be
there in just a quilt why of course I
don't know what to quote this please
comment for me so I've learned rain
robot yeah very functional robot rain
dance run hobbies Running Bear you know
whatever you want baby everyday I'm
shuffling sorry I'm so sorry
yes snake it must be a thing yeah suck
damn it hahahaha seriously it's gonna go
into am i waking Edgar up sorry
go back to sleep again but yeah but you
said you do [ __ ] that [ __ ] yeah this
is definitely a snake there it is
snake I didn't guess it's person I guess
it doesn't count
oh nice he farted team what do we get
don't play with me Edgar
I'm gonna guess we mean T oh yeah that's
titties oh come on tree of course she
tell us
let's go whoa table titty tongue damn it
Tisa tehsil trombone marine ambereen
tambourine now let's forget the word for
that thing we're getting to the end of
the alphabet you underpaying
nice upset Oh what's next umbrella in
Sweden we call them panoply and when I
was a kid I kept calling the pair apply
gives out on cuz I'm stupid I don't know
upwards
and be these vicious victory face yeah
got it
look at that a beautiful vase what is
this
Oh what are these called in English I
don't know the word Oh a vacuum bill eh
we're village I'm sorry he's got to be
clean I'd be clean everywhere there you
go water no am i doing to these poor
villages okay next step okay that must
be water water waterfall a wheel wagon
so Rock Me mama like wagon wheel Rock Me
mama [ __ ] please walruses are not that
skinny they're fat as [ __ ] how do you
even fit in there
I think of waterfall is gonna come what
do you think I hope ah ah always one
step ahead aren't you always one step
ahead
this games really nice to play just like
enjoyable experience I gotta say alright
sorry I got caught up there's X I don't
know many words and X surcease that's a
name that's not a x-rays
Oh a sila phone right nice xylophone
we call these it's such a weird winning
why yesterday yo yo yo yo yo I don't
know why I forgot the [ __ ] way to yo
you last letter write Z exam super
Swedish invention by the way you're
welcome
oh my god zebra Oh sexy sexy as snore
he's gonna snore isn't he
can I come up how am i doing through
this poor zebra oh oh my god it's so
creepy ah dude what is going on
I can't oh that's really weird
the end
what an amazing little game I'll leave a
link through in description if you want
to experience it yourself there's a lot
of fun a lot a lot of fun you can tell
the guy or
I don't know who makes these games
really improved a lot as well and just
amazed by the talent it's really cool so
there you go the alphabet metamorph abet
rather I hope you enjoyed it I had a lot
of fun playing with you bros and leave a
like if you enjoyed and I'll see you in
the next one as always stay awesome bros